is the new iPhone 15 Pro Max better than
the s23 ultra well from the new
redesigned titanium frame in the thinner
display bezels to the new 5x camera and
the faster USBC Port yes the iPhone is a
better phone but it's definitely a bit
complicated now I know all of you
Samsung fans are probably headed into
the comments to rage comment and call me
biased because I'm obviously wearing an
Apple Watch and you got me yes I'm an
apple Fanboy and I have been ever since
the iPhone 6s but don't forget that last
year I flat out gave the win to the s23
ultra over the 14 pro Max multiple times
both in terms of it being a better phone
overall and in terms of the camera
performance because it killed the 14 pro
Max but this time around after 3 months
with my 15 Pro Max I've got to say sorry
Samsung because the iPhone is the clear
winner but wait stop I know you Samsung
fans are probably headed into the
sidebar to exit this video as fast as
possible before you hear something
potentially convincing I'm kidding I'm
kidding but seriously just give me a
chance to explain myself yes I
understand that the s23 ultra is now
almost a year old and the s24 ultra is
almost here and it's a Perpetual cat and
mouse game where the latest Samsung
Flagship beats the iPhone and then the
new iPhone Flagship beats the Samsung
rinse and repeat whatever but it's not
always like that because the 14 pro Max
had a bunch of flaws and drawbacks like
the old slow lightning port and
lackluster camera performance but on the
other hand the s23 ultra was a really
solid phone in many different ways that
honestly beat the iPhone right out of
the game but this time with the iPhone
15 Pro Max it's honestly
different you've got to hand it to Apple
for having the balls to give the new
iPhone a titanium frame because if you
watch some of the videos from Jerry rig
everything it was definitely much more
expensive for Apple to do this and it
honestly gives it a much more premium
feel just knowing that you're holding
titanium instead of basic aluminum like
every other phone out there even the
most budget of phones now I will admit
that the design of the s23 ultra is
really premium with camera bumps that
sit flush on a pane of glass for a
really clean look which is a design that
I wish Apple would go with I even worked
with shy lash on Twitter to create some
renders of what I thought the 15 Pro Max
would look like with a builtin
additional Periscope camera but Apple
went a completely different way and was
somehow able to fit their crazy new 5x
telephoto lens without using a periscope
but with a Tetra prism lens design so
the camera bump stayed the same while
getting a huge camera upgrade as I'll
discuss in just a minute now holding the
s23 ultra in your hands the rounded
sides honestly feel really nice but the
square corners really do dig into your
palms while the iPhone 15 Pro Design has
these really nice rounded off edges all
the way around so it's comfy in your
hands and the weight is perfectly
balanced compared to the s23 ultra which
is really topheavy because of those
cameras so this time around the iPhone
wins in the design category now I will
admit that this year I randomly spawned
a love for genuine leather maybe it's
because Apple decided to to ditch
leather I don't know but I've started
looking for the best leather cases and
I've landed on this the only case I
could find that's fully wrapped in
leather like how Apple used to do it
it's the Aspen case from our sponsor
andar in jet black which comes with
really clicky buttons including for the
action button as well as a soft
microfiber lining with Max safe magnets
built in it's honestly the best leather
case that I could find especially with
andar 9 90day return policy so check it
out using the link below with code
maxtech for a 15% sitewide discount and
speaking of the action button I honestly
believe that Apple nailed it with this
new feature yes I'll admit that it's
nothing new because Samsung flagships
used to have a Bigby button but
everybody hated it because it was easy
to accidentally press so they demanded
that Samsung remove it and they did with
the Galaxy Note 10 but on the 15 Pro Max
Apple's execution was honestly so much
better because one it's above the volume
button so it's harder to press
unintentionally and the software
experience is just so much better with
the options that you have like simply
opening an app like the Tesla app or on
the other hand and this is the part that
makes it so special you can also do
basically anything since the action
button can take advantage of Apple's
shortcuts app to trigger countless
amounts of custom commands like
controlling your smart home lights and
accessories to things that I don't even
understand so that's another win for the
iPhone now the last time I made this
video with the 14 pro Max I had a couple
of different categories that I tested
where it was either a draw or a clear
win for the Samsung like the speakers
the displays the ports the performance
and the cameras so let's dig into those
this year the speakers on the 15 Pro Max
got significantly better now beating out
the ones on the s23
[Music]
ultra yeah that's a clear difference and
getting into the actual displays I
believe the iPhone wins this time around
because the display is still brighter
indoors and Outdoors and now the bezels
are notice thinner and more immersive
which I love now last time around the
biggest flaw for the 14 pro Max was the
lightning Port which had very limited
transfer speeds but now with USBC on the
iPhone 15 Pro Max Apple basically made
it 20 times faster up to 10 gbits per
second which literally matches the speed
of the port on the s203 ultra and on top
of that Apple didn't lock down the USBC
Port since you can connect it to so many
many different devices like when I
connected it to my projector to play
games which is an awesome experience and
it was even able to power the Razer
pelti a phone cooler which was a
surprise to me so with that said there
is now a draw in terms of the ports and
as far as the performance the iPhone
initially had a bunch of overheating
issues but after 3 months they've all
been fixed and I've been shocked at how
well the iPhone's new a17 Pro chip
performs it's the first iPhone in so
many years that no longer has the
display dimming issues during gaming
sessions in our office and now with rate
tracing and metal effects upscaling
support it can play actual AAA game
ports on the iPhone itself which you
don't have yet on Android phones and
thanks to the 8 GB of RAM on the 15 Pro
Max it's just been performing so well
over the last couple of months
especially with its best-in-class C CPU
performance so I've got to hand the win
to the iPhone and finally let's talk
about these cameras Apple did something
amazing this year by being the first
company to upgrade the default photo
output to 24 megapixels across all modes
using the main 1X camera this means that
regular photos and portraits are twice
as sharp and it's instantly noticeable
compared to other phones like the s23
ultra especially when combined with
smart HDR 5 which just makes the photos
look so natural on top of that you can
now change the focus area of portraits
in post when you're editing just in case
the portrait didn't focus on what you
wanted but the Banger feature this year
is a new 5x telephoto camera because it
uses a tetr prism lens design which
allows Apple to have insanely good 3D
stabilization that will let you shoot 5x
videos like this this handheld shot with
crazy good stabilization but even better
the tetr prism lens is able to gather
more light than Periscope lenses which
reduces noise and makes it actually
usable in dimmer situations while phones
like the s23 ultra will switch to the
main lens and crop in because the image
out of the Periscope is way too dark but
the final nail in the coffin was when we
made a couple of unbiased camera
comparisons where we had no idea aidea
which phone took which photo including
one video where we actually invited
professional photographers to join us
and the s23 ultra lost to the new iPhone
15 Pro Max every single time but with
all of that said the iPhone 15 Pro Max
is now a better phone than the s23 ultra
after 3 months so hopefully you enjoyed
this video and if you did go ahead and
comment down below subscribe above and
definitely check out the andar Aspen
case thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video